le maire de sainte luce n'a délivré
aucun permis de grossir hissant dans la
zone les habitations les clôtures les
murets sont là depuis des décennies
l'arrière nouveau nom il ya
effectivement une problématique qui est
posée concernant le cheminement sur le
littoral nous sommes venus ce matin voir
le préfet c'est les services de l'état
puisque il ya une réglementation qui
existe concernant les servitudes
littoral qui est de la compétence de
l'état donc par conséquent nous devons
travailler avec les services de l'état
concernant la situation de ce week-end
chacun a le droit de manifester
cependant on doit manifester respectons
le droit des autres ça peut déranger
ça peut ne pas plaire mais ces personnes
ont des types de propriétés ils ont des
doigts qu'ils ont acquis de ventes
réalisées par l'état il ya une
soixantaine d'années
par conséquent c'est par la concertation
pour la discussion que nous allons y
arriver je crois que là ce matin avec le
préfet nous avons tous les deux la ferme
intention de faire en sorte que cette
loi soit appliquée concrètement sur le
terrain mais évidemment en fonction des
modalités et du respect des personnes
qui habitent le quartier